y comenzamos un cubrimiento especial de
Roland garros Así es Ángela Qué tal
Buenos días segunda jornada del cuadro
principal del Grand islandés hoy con una
nutrida participación de los tenistas
latinoamericanos y además con el estreno
tanto del español Carlos Alcaraz número
uno del mundo y también de Silvio Novak
Djokovic ranking 3 2 de los grandes
aspirantes al título en un torneo que no
tiene a su campeón a Rafael Nadal en la
sede del abierto de Francia se encuentra
nuestra periodista Natalia ruize giraldo
quien nos acompañará en estas dos
semanas del mejor tenis del mundo
Natalia bienvenida empecemos hablando de
la representación de la región hay una
colombiana que ya celebró en esta
jornada
muy buenos días Pues sí se trata de
María Camila Osorio quien logró ganar su
partido ante la rumana Ana bogdan Osorio
que terminó remontando ese partido había
sido el primer set desperdició dos
posibilidades de quedarse con el partido
pero finalmente pues Victoria para la
colombiana que no había clasificado al
tablero principal de Roland garros pero
tras el retiro de magnalli pues esto le
abrió la posibilidad de disputar este
partido y ya en segunda ronda se
enfrentará a Elis mertens quien es la
número 16 de la mundo luego de los otros
latinoamericanos parece que hoy Todos
quieren es remontar ganar remontando eso
hizo Juan Pablo Varillas el peruano que
justamente jugaba en la cancha al lado
de donde jugaba Osorio y ganó su partido
ante shang de China también un partido
en el que el peruano remontó después de
haber perdido los dos primeros sets y
hace pocos instantes es el Peque schmann
quien logra una victoria aquí en su
primer partido de esta temporada aquí en
Roland garros ante esa parte de España
Igual remontada también por parte del
Pequeño e importante también esta
Victoria porque necesita llegar hasta la
cuarta ronda al menos de Roland garros
para no salir de la top 100 su
compatriota
echeverry Tomás echeverry también pasó a
la siguiente ronda había ganado el
primer set ante draper pero Driver pues
se retiró luego más adelante en la
jornada en cuanto Pues a
latinoamericanos tendremos a la
brasileña Beatriz Maya quien se
enfrentará a María de Alemania
una figura sin duda seguir en este
torneo una tenista que viene en alza
tremenda esa remontada del Peque schward
viniendo de dos sets abajo perdiendo
ganando en una temporada que está
haciendo muy difícil para